hello and welcome to this video yeah
this is so sad slightly different layout
and I'm experimenting a little bit quite
obviously let's see how this works out
and the real novelty comes a little bit
later it also looks a little bit
different on the left left hand side I'm
using a different recording software
anyway let's see what happens in this
game playing God want this is some let's
not promote but I can actually promote
okay and the goldman this is some
grandmaster roost em off let's see i
mean i can go d5 taking us also not bad
but i think in general this is not a bad
form of benoni here for white oh no no I
can take it's not they're not the only
way to do it you can also just develop
yeah let's just develop this is fine
Bishop g4 was a little bit annoying so
what does he try to do him some kind of
b5 let's stop that
yeah I got wounded somewhat low rated
yeah he's sometimes ha close to 2,600 so
a little bit surprising that he is just
down in my rating range okay I'm and
wonder how to do the same Bishop to d3
Bishop to e2 that's not invest too much
time and be quick look to be eight okay
doesn't really look like be five is
going to be an option soon yeah okay 95
but that's not a not a big deal I can go
to e3 with the Queen and then Bishop age
6 I don't mind that at all so let's just
centralized b6 that wasn't it doesn't
look like a very essential move I'm very
happy with this position to be honest
Bishop to h6 is just around the corner
he doesn't have much in terms of
activity here yeah and then if I after
the trade f4 will be strong this is a
very nice position for white Bishop to
have three and then e5 that's not very
comfortable and he Wow do you have to do
this you're in bad shape so i can put
the bishop over to e6 that's one thing
that comes to mind
yeah nine ma but I will put it here and
play at 50 g 4 and so on going for an
attack and b5 is the only sort of
counter play here I wonder if that was
actually correctly I could have taken
unplayed if I've that stretches its
stronger right Oh takes it that looks
weird so how to do this King here and
then we'll catch one that's where I
cannot believe this at all there should
be an absolute disaster i take andrew
cage five how are you surviving this
let's see
b2 is hanging which is unfortunate ok
I'll start with this this is this should
be correct anyway the thing is if I
actually pray will gauge seven and then
queen age five how does it defend this
look h7 Cree Nation recheck and tween
age five this is threatening tons of
maids this one some wacky stuff and it
clattered that wins come on why what is
that what is that what is that yeah that
should win I don't see a defense here
rook age eight Queen f7 is made some
wacky you I don't know Bishop everyone
or something but yeah this is the only
thing that could work so i can check on
g6 i have some checks but I don't see a
maid so rook takes Queen takes be too I
don't have a safe spot for the king
yes I really knowing that that would be
in a real real shame I currently don't
see you win yay unfortunately I only see
drums chick it's probably a drone okay
okay let's check this first king edge
aid I don't get there I mean maybe
something they looked it two wins I'm
not saying this isn't the case it might
be time warning hmm am i risking
something I think I do a king rook takes
Queen B to probably losers actually I do
I just need to go here may be roped it
to I mean this still feels like i can
play it without risking anything as i
have the draw in the in the in hand
basically my idea now would be to move
the King to g1 and then cook h2 but
probably bishop age three to save them I
also cannot bring the neither then night
around somewhere the night is good day
of course but ok now if I take with this
the screen to have three so but it
doesn't threaten a check or anything
what if i take this
it's drawing hand and anyway and i have
f six at the end that could win that
could win there's no check right
threatening made so he has to take it
you have the end I go f6 check check now
i have 6 i'm not blowing this but i
think it does work look on the 7th maybe
but i think it think i win i have nine
seconds oh wow this one Queen age 6 made
I know jack didn't see that one okay I
probably lose this on time maybe own
position I don't know what I am okay
yeah okay I should have taken the draw I
mean probably I'm winning like four
effects on time ok let's secured losing
a sick but ok I didn't want to take the
draw after having completely crushed him
actually ok now that's a new feature
that I'm trying to try to do let's see
if you can can pull up the analysis now
with with the engine so it is probably a
complete win everything else would be
really weird so this this look h7 dress
is winning Queen age 5 Bishop everyone k
is this and what is winning now this
also wins but the car did win is this
and now the movie form ok now
threatening a book checks a-ok that
covers the thing that is so tied down
that it doesn't have
move here huh I if he goes like this I
can take it I am the bitchiest I can go
up actually okay well it's not not super
easy to do this but ok i was playing
rook t2 here trying to win of course you
can always draw it this also should win
right claw so this is why this and now I
should take but this losses due to a 6 I
can take with the rook of course ok well
I had no time when the clock rookie 7
was still a good try this is this is
plus a million right here plus 10 yeah
okay I spent too much time in the in the
process here maybe I mean located Luke
h7 is not exactly difficult i should
just play that quicker ha other than
that i'm happy i mean this was the
complete destruction he was still a up
like him this is a completely bad
position for black I'm really kind of
surprised that stop fish just gives +1
probably you need needle needs a little
bit more time to to see how bad this
position is it wants to prepare at age
four but I don't see the point now it
probably needs a little bit more depth
to see how bad it is just 1.4 is not
enough and yeah that's the dead got to
be a real bad benoni here after this
sound yeah Black is suffering you can
actually argue i think after this i'm
here like here here i should actually
take a play 5 and this is confirmed by
the engine yeah this is stronger right
this is a stronger even now I can't
debate that it's both pretty good
it should be salmon yeah the engine is
just on depth 17 it has to be a little
bit deeper to produce something
meaningful but things Black has very
little counterclaim and this g4 and so
on is very dangerous 0.4 yeah come on it
needs more time probably to see how bad
this is because black has no play
whatsoever it probably doesn't have to
be as terrible as it got but it's pretty
bad yeah i just took too long here to
play this rook h5 also wins and then
take on g5 yeah well okay that that's
really not a big deal rook h7 I should
do but zone yeah the term time
management is this is important the game
itself I'm Prime quite i'm quite happy
with okay i hope you enjoyed that and
please give me feedback on how this
layout is working out now with the
analysis after the game ok guys thanks
for watching bye bye